you guys here with Yanni Palmieri yeah
we're not going to keep you very long we
know that you have prep to do for your
tie break we're just going to ask you
this why didn't you take the pawn here
because I'm Immortal so that's that's
the only question I mean anyway I felt
like it's like winning by any sequence
of moves because I mean look at this
position
you know speaks to it first speaks for
itself yeah like but
I mean uh I thought I mean frankly I
thought like any singles of moves at
least to Victory but I mean once I let
him like put King 7 Bishop D7 I think
it's easy anymore yeah definitely not
and at the end of the day okay I just
wandered the trugly one Rook C1 uh I
mean after King Governor give one check
I can't protective C1 because it's uh
you actually blundered it yeah it's okay
I'm not sure I wasn't going to make a
draw anyway uh so far so so fast
yeah but probably at some games before
this tournament I got lucky and at this
point
nothing to be proud
yeah and you still can win the singfield
cup you still have a playoff to play
against alireza uh your thoughts about
the match coming up I don't care
why don't you care I mean okay if I play
like this game that's probably nothing
could help me so
I mean if I play like uh I don't know if
I can't take a pawn in one move so yeah
probably I go have some rest and I'll
see what happens well you do exactly
that the playoff is in a couple of hours
and we'll see that action
um good luck in the playoff in Nepal